this timeline here covers 200 000 years
from 200 000 years into the past to the
present and just to get a sense of the
scale of this if we were to go 2 000
years ago to the time of the roman
empire that would be roughly here on the
timeline if i were to say when were the
pyramids built that would be roughly
there on the timeline so by human
standards this is a very long period of
time and i didn't choose this time span
arbitrarily 200 000 years is about how
long we believe anatomically modern
humans have been on our planet our
subspecies of homo sapiens sapiens
now the reason why i show these stone
tools is because the the the ages the
periods of modern humanity or even
pre-modern humanity are named after the
types of tools that have been found in
archaeological digs so most of even
pre-human
or near pre-human and human history has
been the
has been the paleolithic period or old
state
stone age paleo
paleo for old lithic come from coming
from lithos for stone
so paleolithic the old stone age is the
great bulk of human history and there's
also a mesolithic thick that comes about
fifteen twenty thousand years ago but
then around ten thousand years ago the
stones have a much more polished
appearance to them things like this and
so that period from about ten thousand
years starting with about ten fifteen
000 years ago depending what part of the
world you look at is referred to as the
neolithic period
neolithic
referring to new stone
and on top of this timeline i have also
shown what's happening at a very large
scale climatically on the earth so these
blue periods are ice ages and these
reddish orange periods are the periods
in between ice ages and so you can see
the last ice age ended
roughly fifteen thousand years ago and
it began roughly a hundred and ten
thousand years ago
now i'm giving you all this context
about these paleolithic neolithic and
the ice ages because we're gonna talk
about probably the most important
series of events or innovation in all of
human history
and that is agriculture
agri
culture
for most of human history over this
paleolithic period over most of this
timeline going up about until about 10
or 15 000 years ago our ancestors were
hunter gatherers they would have to
chase the game wherever it might be they
couldn't settle down in one place maybe
there were a few that were near some
sources of
of fish where they might be able to do
some basic fishing but they would have
done hunting like this they would have
done gathering which means getting
berries or mushrooms where they could
find it it probably was eating a lot of
things like insects and that is most of
human history
but then around 10 or 15 000 years ago
we have
the advent of human beings taking nature
into their own hands instead of saying
let's just follow the game wherever the
game might migrate to
let's actually domesticate these animals
let's take some of them start breeding
them so they're more suitable for human
consumption so that they are easier to
raise maybe more robust and we will we
will breed them and we will raise them
for milk for meat
we also started to domesticate plants
instead of saying okay let's just gather
those berries there where it happens to
emerge
let's actually start to plant things
and on a very predictable way be able to
harvest them and so have a more
predictable food supply both of these
things allowed human beings to have a
higher population density to start to to
settle down to have a more sedentary
life and this is a huge huge huge deal
just to get a sense we believe that the
carrying capacity for
the planet for human beings as
hunter-gatherers is 10 million
people and that is what we estimate the
world population was at around the time
of the last ice age or shortly
afterwards and that's because a tribe of
100 hunter-gatherers is going to need 50
square kilometers
to 100 square kilometers to hunt and
gather from
or actually 500 for some of the
estimates i've seen
and it might seem like a lot of area
that you would need to hunt and gather
from but imagine if you and your family
had to go live in the woods now how much
food could you actually find you would
have to walk miles and miles per day if
you're trying to hunt you would have to
walk miles and miles per day to get
whatever
wild grains or berries or whatever or or
mushrooms or whatever or insects that
you might consume
but then with the advent of agriculture
it allowed for a much much higher
density population in fact going from
the birth of this
of agriculture which happens in the
neolithic period the the dawn of
agriculture is coincides with the
neolithic period they're often used
somewhat interchangeably going from that
period 10 15 000 years ago to the time
of ancient rome so we're talking you
know on the order of 10 000 years the
world population with agriculture
exploded from 10 million to roughly
250 million and that's
25x and we know that from the time of
rome till now another 2000 years with
agriculture
our population has gone up 28x it's
growing exponentially to 7 billion and
there's no way that we could have had
this level of density without
agriculture
now a key question is is why did
agriculture emerge right then
well one theory is as well it seems to
be only and i put only i'll say only in
quotes only a few thousand years after
the end of the ice age maybe you had
positive climate change at least from a
human point of view
that allowed land to be uh
to support agriculture that seems like a
reasonable theory although you might say
well we've had other periods where we
didn't have an ice age how can we see no
evidence of agriculture then
and one
counter-argument or explanation i've
heard for that is
anatomically modern humans started to
emerge around 200 000 years ago but that
doesn't mean that they're the way they
thought or that their brains were the
same as modern humans and so maybe in
this period the human brain
just wasn't capable of of performing or
thinking of agriculture
other theories are is that the human
population through hunter-gathering kept
increasing over time and it was right
after the last ice age that you really
got close to this this critical
mass of population at which point it for
every extra human to be born well
another human would would not be able to
live or not be born because there was a
fixed supply of food as hunter gathers
and so you could say out of necessity
maybe a tribe here or a little group
there started to say hey we what if we
started to if we started domesticate
some of this cattle or if we started to
plant crops all of a sudden they would
start to have a higher density and their
population could increase and not only
would they be able to survive
but they could also be
very dominant in things like conflict
once you start having agriculture and as
agriculture advances as i mentioned
these people could be more sedentary
they wouldn't have to move around
they wouldn't have to move around all of
the time that allows them to
create
even defensive structures you could have
specialization where not everyone is
having to worry about
specialization not everyone is having to
worry about food all of the time and so
you could develop warriors you could
have technology developing especially
weapons and so not only would that tribe
or that group be able to get higher
density but they would be able to defend
their property in fact they would
probably care a lot more about property
because they use it to farm versus
hunter-gatherers might just view that as
their territory that they wander over
in order to find food now whatever the
actual cause of the birth of agriculture
it has had profound implications on our
society you would not have had the birth
of city-states
without agriculture city-states had
high-density populations they needed
they could not have been supported with
hunter-gathering you could not have had
the the development of technology which
people needed more time you needed
specialization in order to have that
it's
i would say fair to say
we wouldn't even have our modern our
modern civilization would not have been
possible without agriculture i would not
be making this video to you right now in
fact most of us wouldn't have even been
up around on the planet because the
planet wouldn't be able to support our
really immensely large population
without not only agriculture but an ever
advancing
technological or technologically
advancing agriculture so it might seem
like a small thing you go from
hunter-gatherer to agriculture but it's
been one of the most maybe the most
profound oh well it's probably up there
with language and writing things that
have defined
what makes humans humans
and to get a sense of where this
agriculture was
born
here's the various regions that we
believe agriculture emerged from
the levant
right over here in the eastern
mediterranean modern day middle east
syria israel palestine iraq southeastern
turkey this is one of the areas where we
think agriculture first emerged on the
order of
10 to 15 000 years ago we believe rice
came from china i've seen estimates
anywhere from six to thirteen thousand
years ago you have the potato and other
crops coming from the andes thousands of
years ago and this is just a sample of
the areas where we see agriculture both
domestication of crops and animals first
emerging and what's interesting is over
time we're likely to discover other
places as we have more archaeological
digs and we find more fossil evidence of
ancient ancient agriculture and ancient
peoples
and even the time frame where we believe
this happened the ten thousand twelve
thousand fifteen thousand years ago
that's likely to maybe move back a
little bit as we discover older and
older evidence so i'll leave you there
but the big takeaway is most of human
history
we were not only making rough stones for
our weapons and our tools but we were
chasing animals wherever we could find
it we didn't have predictable food
sources we were we were gathering uh
fruits and and and grains and insects
wherever we could to support our
families and there was a limit on how
many humans could be around but shortly
after the end of the ice age it all
changed you had a population explosion
and we think that is due
to agriculture